elles sont nombreuses les anciennes
gloires du football martiniquais à
revenir sur la mythique pelouse du stade
louis achille seul stade éclairé à
l'époque de grands footballeurs comme
claude cayol ils vont luc b air martial
aurélie à victor jean baptiste roger
modeste encore pour les femmes charlène
marie jeanne qui tire sur cette action
ont marqué le ballon dans notre île ce
tournoi tu as gep est donc une vitrine
du football d'antan football très
alléchant c'est aussi l'occasion de se
rappeler le bon vieux temps aussi ravi
par ce genre les amis où on a joué
pendant longtemps on se rend compte
l'air et on discute les années passées
les retrouvailles sincères sa section
d'intéressant nous c'est les anciennes
gloires des gones a fini de jouer on ou
non qu'on est plus une belle fête et
cette fête est cuit dans mon calendrier
tous les ans le point mi novembre date
est ici qu'on rencontre méhari des
entreprises une sélection de la presse
et une sélection des obédiences
religieuses font partie de la
manifestation qui a été rehaussé cette
année par la présence du talentueux
ailier droit du paris saint-germain de
l'as saint-etienne c'était difficile
j'ai joué j'ai joué j'ai participé je
suis content que je voulais participer
pour le tournoi
des anciennes gloires je jouais avec des
anciens alors ça reste encore très
technique mais physiquement c'est dur
avec la chaleur cette troisième édition
du tournoi des anciennes gloires
entreprises presse a été un succès hier
j'avais la foi et aux voies du jeu du
rôle de l'otan
il faut avoir la foi j'ai pas douter du
tout et de coach à la fois il ya les
résultats ça me fait plaisir de riz sont
pourtant c est ça fait depuis mardi que
moi je suis là est vraiment me passe de
bons moments et c'est ça qui est
important
à l'abordage gagne le tournoi pour la
troisième année consécutive
vivement l'édition 2020